one of the great things about the visual
effects branch is that we have what's
called a bake-off every year and what
happens is that there is a group of the
effects people in the branch who
determine what we call the long list
there's seven films that are that are
chosen and then those films are
presented to the entire visual effects
branch and the entire visual effects
branch views 20 minute clips from each
of those films that are put together by
the filmmakers the visual effects
supervisor typically gets up and has
some opening and closing remarks to help
explain what you're looking at but we
watch those Clips and then at the end
after seeing those those seven films the
7 20 minute clips we actually vote on
three that we hope will become the
nominees for Best Visual Effects and a
motion picture and it's it's a terrific
process it's it's very democratic and
egalitarian and it's great to see all of
the key visual effects practitioners all
together in one night once a year